Speaker 1: The assassination conspiracy theory, by
the way, continues. This started last week after
the FBI search warrant was carried out at Mar
a Lago against Donald Trump's at Donald Trump's
house. And very quickly thereafter, you started
hearing from some individuals that this is the
first step in a plot to assassinate Donald Trump.
Some would say that it's a deep state plot. Others
said it's just a plot. We now have yet another
one of these. And this time it's Rudy Giuliani.
Rudy Giuliani. And this is not Rudy Giuliani
on your screen, by the way. This is, I guess,
the interviewer. Rudy Giuliani now believes that
Donald Trump is in danger, that the deep state
may kill him. Incredible. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Said something before. In third
world countries, in banana republics, they
arrest the former opponents, they kill them,
they kill them, they arrest them, their people,
families. Trump should be in any fear of the
deepest of the nation, maybe killing them. I do.
Speaker 1: I do. The Deep State. This might all be
part of the Deep State planning to kill Trump.
Speaker 2: Well, I was putting him in jail in
many different ways. I do. I mean, the
amount of hatred generated toward him
is the kind of hatred we worry about
that would set off a sick person. I mean,
if there is anything to the fact that now.
Speaker 1: Rudy is right about one thing,
sick people, as he calls them, can be set off. But
if anything, they're going to be set off by Trump
and others weaponizing a legal action by the FBI.
That's a legal not illegal a legal action by the
FBI. And saying that it's the FBI that must be
abolished. It's the DOJ that must be abolished.
It's Merrick Garland, who's the wrongdoer.
That's the stochastic terrorism here. Now,
just as a reminder, a lot of people are
jumping on the assassination bandwagon.
Here is Steve Bannon. This was last week.
Speaker 2: And I agree. I do not think it's beyond
this administrative state and their
deep state apparatus to actually try to
work on the assassination of President
Trump. I think everything's on the table.
I think security ought to be at the highest
it's ever been. And honestly, I think he
ought to. And I think he should
have. I've flown down in Mar a Lago
this morning, walked out there.
Speaker 1: So Steve Bannon jumping
on the bandwagon. This could be part
of the deep state assassination plot.
And then also a guy named Bernie Kerik, a very,
very extensive criminal record. Has Bernie Kerik
also doing the assassination conspiracy theory?
Speaker 2: And I just put out a tweet about this.
If you remember back in 2016 where I went right
before he got elected, I was in Washington,
D.C. I was at a couple different social
events and I heard people talking.
They said the Democrats want this guy so bad
that they wouldn't put assassination behind it.
And I'm going to tell you something.
They've tried impeachment.
They've tried another impeachment. They've tried
one investigation after another. This is about one
thing. This is about stopping him from running
in 2024. And I'm going to tell you something.
I'm not into conspiracies. Right. I'm not.
Speaker 1: But here's one,
the anti-government rhetoric.
Speaker 2: This is the first
time in my lifetime that I would say I
am deathly afraid for Donald Trump. I
would not put assassination behind these people.
Speaker 1: Now, the main thing, you know,
with with a lot of these conspiracy theories
we start getting into is their motive. Is it
possible to carry it out? Why would it? Etc.,
etc.. I genuinely have not heard one reasonable
answer to the question. If there were a deep
state assassinations plot against Donald Trump.
Why would they need to do a legal FBI
search warrant at his home as part of that
conspiracy to kill? Why would you if you
ultimately just want to kill the guy,
why do you get Merrick
Garland and Christopher Wray
and a judge to. Okay, going forward with this
search warrant, attracting all sorts of attention?
If the plan is just to assassinate Trump. It
seems completely unnecessary. And, you know,
nobody said that these were criminal geniuses,
but it just doesn't really make any sense
if you have any answer to that. Why
would a search warrant, legally done,
have anything to do with an assassination plot
by the Deep State? Let me know and I'll follow up